um okay so if someone gets your CD
physically and they look at the back you
have obviously you got West Coast cam
you got sugarfree shout out to sugarfree
the legend I need you to help me get
connected with him sure I got you I got
you um but then you also have Samuel
Jackson and the notorious b listed his
features yeah yeah yeah um explain
both I just feel like it's always weird
when you looking at a track list and
somebody voice pop up who the [__] is
that and I just put that there like um
obviously on Spotify I didn't try to
infringe on their audiences but I wanted
people to know that that voice you hear
is going to be biggie this voice is
going to be Sam Mar Luther King or
Samuel Jackson or Cedric the Entertainer
you also have um the guy who plays Jesus
um in the music video for slink slink
Johnson yeah shout out to slink Johnson
he did a really good job on on Freddy
Gibbs album too he kind of was like a he
did one of the skits on his album uh and
he did great on your music video yeah
yeah uh what's it save something for the
[__] for [__] some for the [__]
for [__] which is um an ODed
to uh it's weird because right there's a
men with bedazzled anklets that and just
just straight men impeding on women's
beauty standards in the first place
completely top to bottom I tell them all
the time straight man Cyrus my shooter
over there got two earrings in that you
know what's funny that 30 40 years ago
that would have been L FR at 20 years
ago that's normal mhm when I was growing
up my dad used to always tell me if you
have an earring on a certain side of
meant that you were gay yeah oh yeah
like the right side right and if you
have both it's like what girls do yeah
that's true and that that used to be
that way that used to be that way then R
Kelly kicked that down cuz he had them
things him and AI you know what I'm
saying but now this album in general cuz
you're listen man if y'all don't follow
glasses on Twitter he's one of the most
frustrating entertaining follows ever
there are very few things that I I so me
and you it's funny because I'm getting
ready to redo the whole set and a lot of
my set is going to be dedicated I bought
a doggy style on viny the OG vinyl good
that's good and I bought the uh o OG
cassette i' have had three copies of the
C I was a kid that's a good one but you
and I are very aligned with some hip-hop
opinions some very very some and four
out of 10 most of most of the ones that
we're very passionately dug in on have
to do with Snoop and have to do with
doggy style because doggy style is the
most important hip-hop album in my
entire life sure and it's the most it's
the greatest one of all hipop and I I
kind of have like a three album where I
could be like there this is my goat
album right it's Illmatic it's Doggy
Styles probably get rich your die trying
it in any order that those could be one
two or three on Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday whatever but doggy sty is the
most important in my life that's fair
and in my opinion Snoop Dog somehow
while being the most famous rapper in
the world by far still underrated he's
underrated yes agree how is this a
possibility by the way my bucket list
interview I hit his guy Kev once a month
and I'm like dude I'll go to the it's my
bucket list alltime interview if I can
interview Snoop I might cry cuz I want
to explain to him me getting doggy style
on accident change the path of my life
but how is Snoop still
underrated
how does that happen well he's the
greatest hip-hop artist of all time
right but if you favor certain Styles
maybe Snoop won't fit that style so
immediately he's from the West so that's
going to immediately take credit from
the the Cornerstone of hip hop in New
York or the East Coast that's going to
be a Cornerstone issue that he's not
from the right East he's from the West
um his style is like a
oneoff you know what I mean to me is
like a descendant of like shorten L cooj
super smooth you know what I mean but
you can see he's such a hip-hop kid like
First videos you can see the special ed
in his movements how he moved and how
smooth he was um I think the majority of
it
is one he's from the west coast and not
from the East two would probably
be he's alive
M he's alive that's real real [__] you
know what I mean he's alive
and that's really important which is
even greater because you look at him now
and he's probably like
still the most
recognizable you know rapper on the
planet no I I do say that I say there's
certain artists that if God forbid they
passed away would shoot to the greatest
of all and I I really think think that
about Kendrick like I tell people like
oh yeah we we really kind of don't
appreciate Kendrick like we should
because if he passed away tomorrow for
whatever reason he's the goat um he's at
least he's at least like solidified in
that conversation in the same way we
talk about p and it's really dope and I
try not to comment on dot because you
know dot is my friend and somebody I I
love to death you guys have done records
together way way deeper you know mean
this [__] really my partner but it's
like he's also a generation undermines
so I have to listen to a lot of younger
people tell me versus me giving my cuz I
I have [__] that I'm looking like yeah
Scarface you know what I'm saying scarf
it's like as much as I love DOD it's
like Scarface you know me he ra do is
like well I would just say cuz like we
put biggie in certain conversations
based on two albums when he was alive we
got two albums that's them them albums
is [__] that well no those albums are
incredible but what I'm saying is if you
if if you look at just like if some
happen to dot it it'd be frantic it'd be
frantic it it it would probably re it
would probably reshape hip-hop at that
point per I think unfortunately people
sometimes when they
leave uh prematurely they get
appreciated more and I think we've seen
that happen a lot time and time again
over the last decade or or or or their
Spirit can be free to roam about the
cabin yeah cuz I think a lot of times we
don't get into like even with nip right
I always felt like people look at gang
bangers and feel like I can't relate
right even though like you know [__]
is regular human beings but they can't
relate and I think it became so
important for people to to get what he
was on when he passed away cuz it made
him more
right people really look at ganging like
like a he-man sport like oh man if they
die I don't care or you know or they
can't die or they did something to die
or they in prison you know versus some
dude just really running a business and
having a problem and somebody taking his
life and I think there's nothing more
human than that so I think that's what
happened with him